give directly is the non-profit that
lets you send cash directly to the
world's poorest household which is more
cost effective than so many other types
of giving it's how you know you're
maximizing your donations help us reach
our goal of fifteen thousand dollars by
the end of the year go to give
directly.org Pacman
well folks it finally got me I have
coveted those of you who follow me on
social media already know many of you
sending well wishes a few of you sending
horrible messages and you were summarily
blocked I guess I should say
um I have to tell you that I had about a
28-ish hour period where I was as sick
as I remember being in my entire life
and everybody in the house has it my
girlfriend has it uh the little baby has
it um fortunately my my daughter
actually seems to be having the the
easiest go of it and you know it's
interesting because on the Thursday and
Friday show
I felt as I spoke that I had a little
something in my voice that didn't sound
quite right and surprisingly no one
emailed me about it I often get emails
uh you know from from many of the mobs
in the audience who say David I've been
around sick kids enough to know you
didn't sound quite right on today's show
or yesterday show and sometimes they're
not even right but nobody said anything
to me about my voice Thursday Friday
and later Thursday about five o'clock we
were already done producing the Friday
show as well I started just not feeling
quite right I I didn't really have a
sore throat but it didn't feel
completely right and I didn't really I
didn't have a cough but I felt just like
a little tickle somewhere in my chest
and then at a certain point you get that
Revelation where you you say to yourself
sir and that's how I talk to myself my
internal dialogue is extremely um uh
polite and and formal I said to myself
sir I think I may have a fever and
indeed I had like 99 and then I woke up
in the middle of the night late Thursday
with like a 100 100.5 fever and
basically from the middle of the night
early Friday until later in the
afternoon Saturday it is as sick as I
remember being in my life and it's not
that my fever was that high it didn't
ever get above 101 but just the most
painful I don't know how to describe but
just painful fever malaise one of the
worst headaches I've ever had and just
really horrible and then I you know I
quite literally couldn't do anything I
watched World Cup games and thankfully
Argentina won on Saturday it would have
been extremely you know adding insult to
injury to see Argentina lose while
having covid
um and it was very clear you know I had
a an insane sweating episode and then my
fever seemed to break and I have been
feeling better and better the cold came
in after like I had really no cold
symptoms at first and then later I
started to get stuffed up I'm I got a
bunch of trump Sudafed which is why I'm
all hopped up on it right now that's a
joke by the way uh no but I did uh use
yesterday I used DayQuil to to manage
the daytime congestion and
um long story short it morphed into a
cold after the really horrible period
and then my daughter got the fever and
then my girlfriend and it's all rotating
and it's crazy and I learned about the
existence of Tylenol suppositories for
babies that's probably we probably need
a bonus Show episode on Thailand all
suppositories we'll skip that for today
but long story short
I'm not on Pax lovid or Pax livid and
the reason is my doctor said
um your health status and the severity
of the symptoms don't really warrant it
and there's some not great side effects
sometimes with the Pax lovid and or Pax
love it I don't know everybody says it a
different way it's a caramel caramel I
don't know the Pax livid and also you
can get this rebound covet after seven
to ten days it'll get rid of your
symptoms quick uh but then seven to ten
days later you could have a rebound and
then you can't take the packs of it and
so then you kind of have to just uh
suffer through it so we made the
decision which seemed like the the
obvious one not to take that and let's
hope it's just a recovery from here so
those of you who are watching know I'm
wearing 12 masks today no I'm by myself
in a studio so I'm not wearing a mask
and that that would be a strange thing
to do on the show but um we're following
all the protocols and doing doing
everything and hopefully my hope is that
in another 48 Hours everybody in the
house will be out of the woods now in
terms of vaccines so oh David or you
know people on Twitter are you
vaccinated aren't you I guess the
vaccine doesn't do anything listen I
have no idea the the the belief there's
two possibilities right
I got as sick as I did because the
vaccine didn't help me in any way
or I didn't get even sicker potentially
risking hospitalization I don't know
because I was fully vaccinated including
with the Omicron uh bivalent vaccine
which I got
um I guess it was a couple of months ago
so I don't know we we it's I only have
myself as a test case on that I don't
know whether or how much sicker I would
have been without it but that's been
that's been the last uh I guess 72 96
hours or something like that so
um let's get into the show there's so
much to talk about I'm glad to be here
and quite frankly I have nothing else to
do because I'm not doing anything so
let's get right into it the Twitter
bombshell that really was not so let me
explain the back story on this Twitter
owner seems weird to say that but yes
Twitter owner Elon Musk started teasing
and promoting
a uh big bombshell related to censorship
and Free Speech
Hunter Biden and so many other things
and apparently the exclusive story was
given to journalist Matt taibi and so
Matt taibi published and we're going to
put it up on the screen a tweet thread
what better way than to break a story
about Twitter
than with a tweet thread Matt taibi
tweeting thread the Twitter files now
one important thing to mention and you
can decide to what degree it matters to
you is it's logical to say why did Matt
taibi get this story
and if you look at his sub stack he says
he had to agree to certain conditions in
order to get this story to begin with so
we're going to evaluate whether this is
or isn't the bombshell that it was
expected to be but he says he got he had
to agree to certain conditions to get
some of the materials and rather than
explaining those conditions in the sub
stack post
he simply says I take my job and
journalism really seriously and you've
got to trust me you've got to trust me
okay so let's go to the Twitter thread
and when you look at it
uh he writes the Twitter files what
you're about to read is the first
installment in a series based upon
thousands of internal documents obtained
by sources at Twitter
the Twitter files tell an incredible
story
from inside one of the world's largest
and most influential social media
platforms it is a frankensteinian tale
of a human-built mechanism grown out the
control of its designer Twitter and its
conception was a brilliant tool for
enabling instant mass communication
making a true real-time Global
conversation possible for the first time
in an early conception Twitter more than
lived up to its mission statement giving
people the power to create and share
ideas and information instantly without
barriers as time progressed however the
company was slowly forced to add those
barriers some of the first tools for
controlling speech were designed to
combat the likes of spam and financial
fraudsters slowly over time Twitter
staff and Executives began to find more
and more uses for these tools Outsiders
began petitioning the company to
manipulate speech as well first a little
then more often than constantly now I'm
not going to go through every single one
of the tweets of his thread we're
linking to to it and I encourage you to
look at it but the long and short of it
is that what this bombshell exposed is
that people in the Biden campaign team
Joe Biden campaign team this was 2020
when Joe Biden was not president he was
running for president and Donald Trump
was the president members of Joe Biden's
team
would ask their contacts at Twitter
to remove what is essentially revenge
porn of Hunter Biden
we're talking about nude images of
Hunter Biden which were being shared
without his consent now is it
controversial
or problematic that there was a back
Channel being used in other words the
tweets that contained the material of
these images of Hunter Biden which are
against Twitter's terms of service and
are illegal in almost every state
revenge porn nude images shared without
the individual in the picture's consent
is it a problem that there was a back
Channel used rather than the public
Reporting System maybe and we can
certainly talk about that but that is
not a bombshell that is not a bombshell
and so this again collapsing into not a
non-story but not a very big story at
all they're talking about oh this
violated the Constitution for example
there's nothing constitutionally even
involved here and legal experts quickly
explained that it's not even a
government suppression of free speech
because it was the Biden campaign it
wasn't even the government saying hey
you've got to act and remove these
images which by the way violate your own
terms of service as well as just about
every state law it was a campaign rather
than the government so that is the story
and you can be the judge as to whether
it is a controversial story or not now I
want to address one other element to
this story which is that there are those
on the right claiming that even my me
personally that that we on the left are
defending Hunter Biden or running
interference for Hunter Biden I really
couldn't care less whether Hunter Biden
goes to prison if he is found guilty of
some crime for which he is charged after
being investigated that's it the problem
with these stories is that number one
this particular story is about revenge
porn and content that violates Twitter's
own policy so this is not a story that
is really where you're gonna get Hunter
Biden and then with regard to other
Hunter Biden stories or allegations
he is not involved in the Biden
Administration the way that Jared
Kushner was the way that Ivanka Trump
was and others have been and so
if you can charge the guy with something
if he did something illegal by all means
do it charge him I don't know anyone on
the left who says oh no he should be
defended or whatever but it is becoming
that which the right says is constantly
wielded against them it's becoming a
Witch Hunt and Republicans plan to
investigate Hunter Hunter
throughout their coming two years in
control of the House of Representatives
absolutely bonkers the truth doesn't
matter they've decided this guy is their
target and so that's what they're doing
Donald Trump's reaction
to the Twitter files is as you can
imagine
completely and totally unhinged Trump
not on Twitter by the way the irony of
that but on his own platform truth
social putting together a very long list
a list of wacky posts and explosions
some of which we will talk about in more
detail but you have to get a look at
what Donald Trump started saying so
Trump's starting with wow that's a
really big story about Twitter and
various forms of government fraud
including specifically election fraud
the same level of fraud took place with
the other big tech companies if not even
worse if that's possible we are living
in a very corrupt country and as they
are saying all over the Internet nothing
will be done about it because the
justice department and FBI are totally
corrupt but they'll keep investigating
boxes that were legally and openly taken
from the White House Trump trying to
make it seem as though the real crimes
like those exposed by the Twitter files
aren't being investigated of course no
such crimes were exposed Trump then
saying Trump was right again on 2020
election most used statement
Trump then saying so with the revelation
of massive and widespread fraud and
deception and working closely with big
tech companies the DNC and the Democrat
Party do you throw the presidential
election results of 2020 out and declare
the rightful winner or do you have a new
election we're going to get back to that
one because that one is so crazy and
insane Trump continuing again Trump was
right again on 2020 election most you
statement
Biden cheated Trump won memes retweets
retroths returned the Diamonds the world
is laughing at the United States of
America and its corrupt and rigged
presidential election of 2020 folks it's
almost 2023.
unprecedented fraud requires
unprecedented cure
I wonder what Mitch McConnell the rhinos
and all of the weak Republicans who
couldn't get the presidential of 20
presidential election of 2020 approved
and out of the way fast enough are
thinking now they are a disgrace to our
great party and our nation which has
become a laughing stock all over the
world then just retweeting and posting
about I mean just spending endless
amounts of time on truth so social truth
Central election interference at a level
never seen before truth social is so hot
even the fake and disgusting news media
is in agreement on that etc etc
this guy has only one hammer and that
hammer is the hammer of I really won the
election and everything is just about
how I won
and how unfairly I am treated I'm the
ultimate victim that is ultimately
Trump's message and the most important
thing he wants to get across for the
most part this is another one of those
unhinged Rants and screeds because he's
Furious that people aren't praying at
his Altar and deferential enough to him
but there is one piece in there that is
particularly horrifying completely
unconstitutional which is demanding
apparently based on the Twitter Story
the Twitter files which we already said
are really no big story
that he be reinstated as president of
the United States we're going to deal
with that specifically a little bit
later in the show make sure that you are
subscribed on YouTube at youtube.com
slash the David Pacman show I do have
covid my voice is a little messed up
bear with me the show continues
I have done a ton of reading about how
to optimize charitable donations we all
have some limited amount we can give and
for me it's important to make sure I'm
giving in the most efficient way when
organizations give cash to families in
need about 90 cents on the dollar
actually goes to the recipient instead
of only about 50 cents of relative
impact with some of the more complex
programs like certain kinds of job
training for example that's why I
reached out to an amazing non-profit
called give directly about partnering
with us because give directly lets you
send cash directly to the world's
poorest households the David packman
show is trying to hit fifteen thousand
dollars in donations to give directly
before the year is up that's equal to
about a Year's worth of expenses and
Investments for 15 families in many
cases use the link below giving families
cash lets them choose for themselves
elves how to improve their lives they
buy food they repair their homes they
start a business they buy medication
they pay for their kids schools give
directly is doing truly incredible work
all around the world when you give to
them you're maximizing every hard-earned
dollar that you donate and they need
your help go to give
directly.org Pacman help us get to
fifteen thousand dollars by the end of
the year the link is down below
all right let's talk about the Kanye
West video in which he says he likes
Hitler he likes Nazis now before I even
get into this I want to say right up
front there are people who are
not in agreement with the things Kanye
is saying but are dismissing this as
merely being a very public mental health
episode and that that's the only thing
the only commentary the only analysis
that needs to be looked at Ben Shapiro
right wing commentator is one of these
people where he says obviously I don't
agree with this stuff he's Jewish being
Ben Shapiro and he doesn't agree that
Hitler was good or whatever
but that this is nothing this isn't it
has nothing to do with politics has
nothing to do with Society or culture
it's just Kanye having
some kind of mental health episode
it is clear from everything we have seen
that there is a mental health component
to this but it doesn't matter
in terms of the effect that this can
have on people who already sometimes
dabble in these sorts of beliefs
anti-semitic beliefs and who need very
little to be pushed
to the next level where those beliefs
grow and grow and grow and they can go
as we saw in the World War II era from
just ideas that crazy people say come on
that's it give me a break into much
bigger and terrible things so let's not
do the thing where we go just a crazy
person doesn't matter there's an entire
movement and by the way
this Nick Fuentes guy who was on The
Alex Jones Show alongside Kanye a couple
of days ago
is are all the things he says also
simply a mentally ill you know a mental
illness episode
less clear so let's just go right into
it these clips are literally beyond
belief except they're not what I mean by
that is if I simply told you six years
ago hey here's a thing that Kanye is
going to say nobody would believe it
but then now of course it's exactly the
stuff that he is saying Kanye West Nick
Fuentes after their dinner with Trump
appearing on the Alex Jones Show you're
not a Nazi you don't deserve to be
called that a demonized well
I I see I I see good things about Hitler
also but you I love everyone and Jewish
people are not going to tell me you can
love
um you know us and you can love what
we're doing to you with the contracts
right you can love what we're you know
what we're pushing with the pornography
but this guy that
invented highways invented the very
microphone that I use as a musician you
can't say out loud that this person ever
did anything good and I'm done with that
I'm done with the classifications every
human being has something of value that
they brought to the table yep and Kanye
wants to fight for the value of talking
about the good things Hitler did now by
the way Kanye has no clue what he's
talking about he says Hitler invented
the microphone most microphones in use
today or thanks to James West who was a
black inventor not because of Hitler
inventing the microphone it's you know
it's completely outrageous uh here's
more of this stuff if you can believe it
I've done a lot of study I think Hitler
was a really bad guy and I repudiate
what Hitler did I understand that the
British intelligence set him up and used
him I like Hitler I don't like Hitler I
don't know there you go and look at the
look at Nick Fuentes with this stupid
grin on his face
this is a big victory folks they've got
one of the most
recognizable well-known uh black musical
artists and celebrities generally saying
I like Hitler this is a major victory
for people like Nick Fuentes and the
white nationalist movement they are
absolutely loving this trying to be
shocking with that I'm not trying to be
shocking I like Hitler I do not I the
the Holocaust is not what happened let's
look at the facts of that and Hitler has
a lot of redeeming qualities
well CNN says why people are evil Nazi
so I mean I I disagree with both
statements but I get the approaches I
don't like the word evil next to Nazis I
think we need to look at
um and the Nazis you might be worse hugs
and shook people down to a lot of really
bad things but they did good things too
we're gonna stop dissing the Nazis all
the time okay
I never had a supermodel
tail
the Jewish media has made us feel like
the Nazis and Hitler have never offered
anything of value to the world okay well
why would the zionists be killing Jews
in mass and Israel with the poison shot
because they'd work for Satan they don't
work for God exactly okay so this stuff
is completely Beyond The Pale I mean
it's it it's beyond any analysis you
can't analyze it for its substance and
there's a moment which is sort of
surreal where even Alex Jones tries to
get Kanye to walk back some of his
statements and Kanye just doubles down
even further I don't
that was amazing uh but I mean just
because you're in love with the design
you're a designer can we just kind of
say like you like the you like the
uniforms but that's about it oh we we no
odds there's a lot of things that I love
about Hitler
and look at Nick Fuentes grinning and
nodding along
a lot of things wow
wow folks this is the what how how can
we say this is a meaningless lone nut
when there's an entire movement behind
the guy there are people who are behind
these messages and they're increasingly
prominent Nick Fuentes met with Trump he
had dinner with Trump the other day and
so it's really important that we not
allow this as sometimes happens with
anti-Semitism I've said it before some
in the audience don't like when I point
this out
uh we shouldn't have a different
threshold for anti-Semitism than we do
for other isms or discriminatory
statements and claims and whatever the
case may be okay this is dangerous stuff
and
when we talk about it it's not about
saying Kanye is the next Hitler that's
not at all what the analysis is
but it's important to remember that
there were lots of people in pre-World
War II era Germany who would say a lot
of this rhetoric that's floating around
about Jews and all the different things
it's just rhetoric it's never going to
go anywhere there's no it has no teeth
there's no way it could ever go anywhere
and when people assume that that's how
more happens now you don't have to jump
to the Holocaust you can just go to well
more societal acceptance of
public shaming of Jews for example right
there's all these little steps in
between before we're at the Holocaust
you don't have to go to that
um one last thing here the uh there was
just an interesting kind of moment where
uh Kanye says that Trump actually loved
Nick Fuentes at the dinner that they
went to this is the future president
you're talking to right now
is Nick your running mate
he's not old enough
yeah Nick how old are you I'm 24. it's
maybe in a few cycles and and Trump
loved Nick he looked at me and said
where did you find this kid yeah now
that's interesting because that's
exactly the type of language Trump would
use where did you find this kid straight
out of Central Casting huh no idea until
what's the guy that wrote the speech
that you didn't like Jason Miller did
Jason Miller lied afterwards after they
found out who you were and what did
Jason say in the press to start off
because it it started to be like a
series of lie after lie after lie and
fake it wasn't a tweet it was a true
social after truth social after true
social so give them the rundown on that
yeah so initially we didn't publish
anything about the dinner it was rumored
that yay went to dinner with Trump then
it was rumored that I was at the dinner
because I walked through the airport in
Miami then there was a statement from
Jason Miller who spoke as a
representative for Trump and he said
well Nick fuentius was not at the dinner
and it was only at that point which was
a lie it was only at that point when we
began to respond then yay said he can't
say that Nick was at the dinner that was
a lie but I mean I actually like the
species of Jason Miller Road maybe yeah
so Alex Jones still desperately trying
to kind of keep some kind of Bridge to
Trump there to some degree this is
extraordinarily dangerous stuff and uh
sure Kanye West probably mentally ill
seems pretty clear but uh we're not
going to write off this entire movement
which by the way has been around for
what thousands of years and say no it's
not meaningful it's not important
because Kanye is mentally ill we're not
going to do it and by the way you've got
to see the reactions of some to this
stuff that happened over the last few
days
Caitlyn Jenner appeared on television
and was asked about the outrageous
statements made by Kanye West including
I like Hitler and I like Nazis and
Caitlyn can come up with nothing more
than I wish Kanye well this reminds me
of another guy we know which I'll remind
you about in a moment here's Caitlyn
Jenner defending Kanye and just saying
Kanye's a good guy I've known obviously
Kanye for a long time
um he's always been very very good to me
um and I just wish him well I I just I
want Kanye to do have you talk to him
well
um
uh not in the last few months especially
when all this stuff has come out I have
not talked to him but I just wish him
the best
um you know he's he's got challenges and
uh I I just hope I'm the best he's
always been very good he's such he's a
really nice guy right I've been around
him my whole life or for the last 10
years and uh I just wish him well you
know I I honestly yeah a lot of people
are disappointed and offended and hurt
by it but now he's suspended on it and I
get it and just saying he's saying
what's in I don't blame him for being
offended I'm offended by it okay
um but uh something's gone Kanye's Kanye
yeah
so absolutely
um electric political analysis there
from Caitlyn Jenner and by the way the I
wish him well stuff I know that this is
sort of like apropos of nothing but it
did remind me of When Donald Trump was
asked about jilane Maxwell the
um sex trafficker former girl friend of
the late Jeffrey Epstein and Trump could
think of nothing else to say other than
he wishes her well as well I'm wondering
did you
turn in powerful men at
I haven't really been following it too
much I just wish her well absolutely
I've met her numerous times over the
years especially since I lived in Palm
Beach and I guess they lived in Palm
Beach I guess but I wish her well
whatever it is I don't know the
situation with prince Andrew just don't
know not aware of it doesn't know
anything about it guys just uh he wishes
her well multiple you know accused
trafficker of women wishes her well so
the folks who you would expect to be
struggling to just completely denounce
Kanye West taking several steps back
well he's always been very nice to me or
he's a brilliant guy or he's a really
nice guy or yeah the stuff he's saying
is wacky but it's just a mental health
episode we've got to condemn this stuff
and we have to make sure that mental
illness or not it's not acceptable
anywhere and it very interestingly by
the way check out the statement made by
Jewish UFC fighter Natan Levy recently I
wish I had it prepared here I just don't
because I just saw it and remembered it
and okay I don't have it but um he was
asked about this and he is taking a much
more aggressive approach than many
potentially on it but uh we we can't
look away and it can't be written off as
merely the roundings of crazy people
that's the important message
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com join pacman.com
there is an election in Georgia tomorrow
it's the special Senate runoff election
to determine will Democrats have a 50-50
majority needing Kamala Harris to be the
tie-breaking vote or will Democrats have
a 51-49 majority in the Senate the race
is in Georgia between incumbent
Democratic senator Rafael Warnock and
challenging Republican Senate candidate
Herschel Walker a former president
Barack Obama you know the guy Obama that
guy he was in Atlanta over the weekend
campaigning for Raphael Warnock you
really have to see this Obama's really
good at this
crushing Herschel Walker for his
unintelligible rants of late including
one in which he talked about what was it
vampires and werewolves take a look at
this
every day he comes up with something
every day
[Applause]
since the last time I was here
since the last time I was here Mr Walker
has been talking about issues that are
of great importance to the people of
Georgia right
like whether it's better to be a vampire
or a werewolf
[Applause]
true
this is a debate
debate that I must confess I once had
myself
when I was seven
then I grew up right
[Applause]
in case you're wondering by the way Mr
Walker decided he wanted to be a
werewolf
which is great
as far as I'm concerned he can be
anything he wants to be except for a
United States Senator right
that's the critical part
[Music]
let me beat him at basketball
but then he admitted
that we've never actually met right
[Applause]
that's typical of Warren but I'm sorry
if Walker regularly telling stories that
are impossible
[Music]
now listen this would be funny
if you want to run him for Senate
that's that's exactly the point and as
I've said before listen it's all fun and
games right Trump running for president
in 2015 2016.
if you had a Republican party that was
more like the Democratic party in which
such an obviously unqualified buffoon
didn't have a shot at the nomination we
could all laugh at the entire Trump
thing he never would have been the
Republican nominee he never would have
become the president of the United
States
that's not the situation we have in the
U.S unfortunately now Rafael Warnock
also spoke I mean it was a rally for him
after all and let's take a look at a
little bit of that
If we're honest I believe in my soul
that Georgia knows that Georgia is
better than Herschel Walker
let's hope
Georgia
Georgia welcome
you
you deserve a senator
who cares enough about the people to
actually know the issues
you or at least an issue if not the
issues
[Applause]
you deserve a senator who actually lives
in Georgia
is that too much to ask and as we
recently found out of course what was
suspected appears to be true Herschel
Walker really lives in Texas and that's
where he declares homestead exemption
and it's a whole other story in and of
itself we're down to the last few hours
if you live in Georgia make sure to vote
we'll have results tomorrow night
Herschel Walker has a brilliant new idea
by the way in the midst of this hectic
campaign and race to the Finish Line
tomorrow Herschel Walker says hey you
know what
we've got all of these IRS or as he
calls them Ras
ents who are going to be carrying guns
let's get them to stop the men in
women's sports this is an incredible
idea coming from a guy who has very few
ideas let's take a listen to it and
instead of trying to keep them safe
they're putting me into women's sports
I'm like wait a minute this is how you
can solve this problem get rid of them
eight or seven thousand res agent that's
going to go after all of us and put one
of those IRS agents in the schools to
take care of our kids that's what they
need to be doing instead of going out to
us with these IRS agents but yet they
don't know how to spend their money now
they want to spend your money yeah did
you catch that I mean did you did you
understand the idea and instead of
trying to keep them safe they're over
there putting me in the women's sports
I'm like wait a minute this is how you
can solve this problem get rid of them
87 000 RS agent that's gonna go with all
of us and put one of those IRS agents in
the schools to take care of our kids
that's what they need to be doing
instead of going out to us with these
IRS agents but yet they don't know how
to spend their money yeah
um now I think that this is obviously
crazy
but it's important to know the truth
about the IRS agent story
the right is framing the hiring of IRS
agents as some kind of
dystopian Crackdown on the people or
whatever the case may be a couple
different things that are important to
understand number one over the next
decade 55
000 IRS agents are going to be retiring
so 55 000 of the hiring of the to be
hired agents are over the next decade
and they're just to replace 55 000 that
are retiring that's number one number
two the IRS is understaffed if you
actually want to hold the wealthy
accountable and make sure that they're
actually paying the taxes that they
should be paying and the things we
always say and that many Republicans say
as well
you need them you need staff to do that
you need employees to be able to do that
and so increasing increasing Staffing
Beyond just replacing those retiring
makes sense and then lastly the entire
gun thing okay it's really a red herring
first of all across the entire country
there's 2100 IRS agents from the
criminal investigation side these are
essentially police who carry firearms
Herschel Walker and others want you to
believe that they're going to be arming
random IRS Auditors auditing people
making sixty thousand dollars a year
because they claim too many deductions
okay that's not what this is that's not
what this is and by the way many
agencies have divisions that are law
enforcement and carry guns if you look
at the MTA right the Metropolitan
Transit Authority in New York City or if
you look up in Boston at the MBTA
they all have like some version of their
Transit Police
they carry guns it's not the subway
operator is now armed okay it's really
not a big deal Amtrak Amtrak has police
yes they carry guns it's not a huge
thing now the good news as far as
Georgia goes is that Republicans
are losing a little bit of Hope now we
have just hours until we know the
results everybody should vote I don't
mention this in order to get people to
take any action or not take any action
if you can vote in Georgia you should
vote in Georgia that's it but
Republicans according to a new political
article which we will link to are
feeling increasingly
Grim is the word that's used here about
Herschel Walker's chances let's indeed
hope that that is the case one other
Herschel Walker story I have a clip of
Marjorie Taylor green radical republican
congresswoman Marjorie Taylor green who
represents the state of Georgia after
all in the House of Representatives
even is admitting
asking people to vote for Herschel
Walker
that's asking a lot take a listen to
this
more to what it looks like than just a
Republican and a Democrat this is the
future of our country this is the future
for our children and it it's also the
way your money is spent in Washington so
um I'm asking you to get out and vote
for my friend Herschel Walker and of
course fellow UGA Bulldog we're always
so proud of him of course for uga's
football team in the years that he
played
and um it would just be wonderful it'd
be great to have a dog up there in the
Senate so a dog yeah she's all but
saying to Republicans listen
you've got to hold your nose and vote
for Walker to block Raphael Warnock from
being a member of the Senate someone
wrote to me and they said David do you
think Marjorie Taylor green means that
it's a lot to ask to vote for Walker
because Walker is a bad candidate or
because Walker is black and I thought
that's a very low blow we have no actual
evidence that that's what Marjorie
Taylor green meant let's not even go
there but it is a theme that even some
of the wackiest Republicans and without
a doubt Marjorie Taylor green qualifies
as one of those
some of the wackiest Republicans seem to
recognize this entire Herschel Walker
thing it's not a particularly good idea
and so Step One is we've got to get
through tomorrow hopefully Raphael
Warnock is uh voted uh wins and stays in
the Senate and um Herschel Walker is
gone and we never hear from him again in
a political space he can go back to
doing whatever else he wants to do the
next step is have Republicans
learned in a sense that it wasn't a
great idea to run these wacky candidates
and that Trump's endorsement alone
doesn't seem to be enough to get some of
them past the Finish Line we saw it with
J.R Majewski we saw it with John Gibbs
we saw it with Doug mastriano we saw it
with Mehmet Oz we're hopefully going to
see it with Herschel Walker will they
learn
and if so is that actually worse for
Democrats in the sense that they might
nominate people more likely to win
that's a story for later in the next 24
hours vote vote vote we're going to take
a quick break make sure you're
subscribed on YouTube at youtube.com the
davidpackman show just a reminder if I
sound weird I have coven I had a brutal
30 hours of fever over the weekend
during which I uh watch world cop and
watched um
oh I watched the new Argentinian film
1985 about the prosecution of uh those
at the head of the military dictatorship
in the in Argentina in the late 70s very
very good film and then Like a Phoenix
rising over the horizon my fever cleared
and now I have a cold but I am here and
that is what matters okay quick break
back right after this
value what we do at the David packman
show remember to support us on patreon
go to patreon.com davidpackman show
where you can get access to behind the
scenes videos The Daily bonus show the
commercial free Daily Show as well as
special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show well I am
going to tell you about a post today in
which the failed former president Donald
Trump defecates on the Constitution now
hold the whoa whoa hold it I'm not
literally going to show you scat videos
so don't you don't have to turn away you
don't have to get the kids out of the
room yet although if absolutely
brutalizing the Constitution and using
it like toilet paper is offensive to you
then maybe you do want to get the kids
out of the room Donald Trump in an
absolute
Constitution destroying rant
demanded for a new 2020 election or to
be reinstated as president of the United
States under the continued false claim
that he is the so-called rightful winner
of the 2020 election Trump exploding on
his platform truth social essential well
call it what you want
over the Twitter bombshell that flopped
into a nothing Burger saying the
following quote
so with the revelation of the massive
and widespread fraud and deception in
working closely with big tech companies
the DNC and the Democrat Party
do you throw the presidential election
results of 2020 out
and declare the rightful winner
or do you have a new election a massive
fraud of this type and magnitude allows
for the termination of all rules
regulations and articles even those
found in the Constitution
he's literally saying the Constitution
is not the supreme law and framework of
the land he's saying when we decide
there are extenuating circumstances you
terminate this is the word terminate
rules regulations and articles he goes
on to say our great quote capital F
founders
I don't know what's weirder that it's in
with a capital f or that it's in quotes
it's both are weird our great Founders
did not want
and would not condone
capital F false and capital F fraudulent
capital e
elections
the Constitution means nothing to them
if it's not convenient this is brutal
brutal authoritarianism it's all
meaningless
unless it is convenient to them and
there Donald Trump says I don't know it
just sort of seems like we've got to
eliminate or circumvent better said the
Constitution so that he can somehow end
up back in office now think for a second
of the insanity of the situation
former president
who lost and is again a candidate is
saying maybe just put me back in office
maybe let's skip me doing two years of a
Republican primary or a year however
like a year and a half
and then in general election and then
having people vote we can skip all of it
terminate as he says what is he thinks
he's Arnold Schwarzenegger terminate the
Constitution
maybe just put me back in power
and the most insane part of this is
Republicans aren't even going that wild
it should be
instantly disqualifying
for a candidate for the presidency to
say sometimes we terminate the
Constitution we just terminate it now if
you want to have a conversation about we
need a constitutional amendment oh okay
well we have a process for that if you
want to have a conversation about
should a document like the Constitution
be revised over time in some more
General sense that's a completely
legitimate conversation to have it's not
about we can never I'm not asking to
have it both ways because many of us on
the Progressive left say
a document that is this old
no matter how great the intentions were
of those who wrote it and believe what
you believe about that right no matter
how great the intentions were no matter
how much how forward looking they
planned to be
at a certain point we have to be able to
say
it needs modern context and you know you
can argue about whether
a few hundred years is enough time but
do we think that the constitution would
be relevant in 500 years in a thousand
years in 1500 years without significant
revision or contextualization sure let's
have that conversation but that's not
what Donald Trump is saying Donald Trump
is not saying there are aspects of the
Constitution which in general need to be
revised modified amended whatever the
case may be Trump is just saying keep
the Constitution the way it is just
ignore it when it comes to me figuring
out a way to get back into power
I'm going to give you one example of a
uh Republican
who
seems like she's not going for this
Insanity unfortunately for a lot of them
uh they are going for it and we're going
to get to that uh probably on tomorrow's
program but here is Alice Stewart she is
a Republican strategist former Ted Cruz
communications director she doesn't like
this but there are many Republicans who
are just kind of like that yeah I mean I
don't agree
but uh Trump may be the best choice we
have the vice versa and I hate to inform
the former president the Constitution
does not like a spouse you can't just
get rid of it when it no longer suits
your purposes the Constitution is here
to protect the rights of all Americans
it is not there to change the past
election of a self-serving American and
he is wrong on this this is absolutely
ludicrous and I guarantee you Jim the
more you ask conservatives and
Republicans about this statement they
will say this is not right and they're
going to accept well we'll see about
that right themselves from these kinds
of statements yeah Alice the
Constitution is not like the buffet at
Mar-A-Lago you can't skip past the items
that you don't like
yeah listen
um I I guess you know there's things
have become the standard has become so
low
I guess I respect Alice Stewart for
saying this but at the same time all
she's saying is we have to mean it when
we say we respect the Constitution you
can't just ignore it when you just want
to use the you want to circumvent it in
order to get back in power
but it is absolutely not true that
Republicans are United against this it
should be political suicide to say what
Donald Trump said terminate the
Constitution so that you can get him
back in power because of Hunter Biden
pictures I mean at the end of the day
that's what we're talking about here but
we're seeing mild criticism from some
wings of the Republican party and uh
this type of thing I mean you know in
2022
a lot of Republicans ran on the election
was stolen and they didn't do very well
so it's at least possible possible that
some of the mainstream Republican party
is going to be further alienated by this
Insanity any clear thinking individual
who actually cares about the rule of law
even if we believe that the constitution
needs to be amended updated changed
whatever
by going through a process not in a rush
because we've got to terminate it to get
somebody back in power we can do that we
can talk about that but this type of
stuff needs to be rejected I have a very
strange video for you I'm not going to
spend a ton of time on this
but Donald Trump issued another one of
these visibly confused statements in
which he defends the January 6th rioters
and there are so many hypocrisies and
double standards here let me play the
video first and of course Trump says oh
the country's going communist and a lot
of this normal stuff let's look at the
video then we'll talk about it
unconstitutionally in my opinion and
very very unfairly and we're going to
get to the bottom of it and you know
what I've said I take it very seriously
I have never seen anything like it at
all levels it's the weaponization of the
Department of Justice and we can't let
this happen in our country because our
country is going not socialist they've
skipped over that they've skipped over
socialism our country is going
Communists now Trump doesn't even know
what either of those terms mean and he
says this often it rallies we went by I
used to say socialists but now I say
communist he has no clue what he's
talking about just remember that what
happens and we can't let it happen we
have to stop it so I want to thank
everybody for working so hard I know how
hard you're working to get Justice for
people that are imprisoned right now and
people that are being tormented can't
let it happen we're going to stop it
we're going to win thank you listen
Trump is talking what you you know you
might be wondering what are they what
are they people are in prison what do
you mean or people are being people are
being uh tortured Trump is talking about
pre-trial detention now we have to take
this piece by piece because this is of
such critical importance first of all
I'm not on the side of the criminals
period okay as I always say if BLM does
something and it's illegal
if antifa does something and it's
illegal there's you know we've had a
protest of whatever crimes whether or
not they are actually part of those
groups because as we know Mass
Gatherings also bring out Bad actors and
are are you really in BLM or not I don't
care guys if you commit crimes you
should be prosecuted and if you're
convicted you should be penalized I say
it about Hunter Biden I don't care about
political orientation and it's the same
thing with the writers now you look at
the capital breach cases you can find
the list okay on the website of the of
United States attorney's office for the
District of Columbia justice.gov
you can read through this and you'll see
the names of these folks and where they
were arrested and what they're accused
of and you see that there are a number
of different crimes many of these are
serious crimes
our opinions matter less
about the individuals then about what is
our approach when we say we are for Law
and Order
when the Trump people say we are for Law
and Order part of it means here is the
law
and we have to allow the process to take
place now they are bringing up
issues about the rioters that they never
cared about before I'll give you an
example pre-trial detention
I've talked about pre-trial detention on
this program for more than a decade and
pre-trial detention is when you are not
given bail or you can't afford bail you
stay in jail until the time of your
trial and I've talked about how this is
um often used as a way
uh or it becomes a way in which
individuals are less able to build a
defense they're not able to afford
lawyers because they can't keep working
while they are uh better maybe a better
lawyer they're not because they're not
able to work while they are in pre-trial
detention Etc I've been talking about it
for a really long time and I've talked
about how pre-trial detention
disproportionately affects uh poor
people minorities it's we've talked
about it
these Republicans never cared about it
now they do because they see hey this
pre-trial detention stuff is really
unfair they're keeping all the rioters
in jail until their trials yes we've
been talking about it for a very long
time it's not being used as a political
weapon against these people this is the
system and we've been complaining about
it for a long time
so there's the hypocrisy and there's the
depravity of saying we finally found
people we believe are worthy of our
defense and they pick the Trump rioters
which is absolutely crazy how dare the
doj go after people
many of whom are on video committing
crimes that's unfair it's a political
Witch Hunt it's Bonkers and we are
seeing the sentences roll in and that's
a very good thing we have a voicemail
number that number is 2192 David P
here's a great little voicemail caller's
mom watches the show on Tick Tock listen
to this
hi David Ryan here from Iowa I uh
I just went home to visit my
uh quite elderly mother and
I noticed
she was watching you on Tick Tock when I
came in and I thought I recognized your
boys
I asked her if
that was David Pacman she said she had
to go back and she said yeah
I told her I subscribe to you and I paid
for the bonus show and
oh the bonus show where you want to make
money yeah everybody else that makes
money to find themselves as bad right
you're great
you know super interesting we're all
aware of all of the problems with Tick
Tock as a platform this has nothing to
do with that in terms of tick tock as a
place to get our message out because
we're using the tools where there is an
audience the growth we have seen on Tick
Tock is wild and even though Tick Tock
audiences skew younger
overall we have not only a young
audience on Tick Tock like in the 13 to
13 to 24.
which is a little younger than like our
core audience which is like 24 to 54. we
also have a sizable 65 plus audience on
Tick Tock just the other day at a
pharmacy
um an older woman came up to me and said
I watched you're the guy from Tick Tock
so
listen The Tick Tock regulation stuff is
going to get sorted out as a platform it
has been a huge place to get our message
out at this point I think I'm getting
recognized as much for being on Tick
Tock as being on YouTube and it's
beautiful to hear this heartwarming
message from the caller okay great bonus
show for you today
the military coveted vaccine mandate may
be ending
and it might be Biden doing it I thought
he was just gonna do all mandates well
apparently not we will talk about the EU
allowing phone calls on flights why
aren't phone calls allowed on flight
well uh why aren't phone calls allowed
on flights we will talk about it and
also New Zealand plans a lot of require
Facebook and Google to pay for news to
pay who what does that mean we will talk
about all of it on today's bonus show
you can sign up at joinpackman.com
foreign
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors give directly is
the non-profit that lets you send cash
directly to the world's poorest
household which is more cost effective
than so many other types of giving it's
how you know you're maximizing your
donations help us reach our goal of
fifteen thousand dollars by the end of
the year go to give
directly.org Pacman